ahorita vamos a hacer un ejemplo un poco
más complicado de descomposición en
fracciones parciales este ejemplo dice
lo siguiente dice 10 x al cuadrado más
12 x más 20 más 20 dividido entre x al
cubo x al cubo menos 8 muy bien el
primer paso es verificar que el
numerador tenga grado menor estricto que
el denominador y aquí si sucede en el
numerador tenemos grado 2 y en el
denominador tenemos grado 3 entonces
bueno aquí está padre no tenemos que
hacer un paso extra si tuviéramos un
grado mayor o igual en el numerador
entonces tendríamos que hacer una
división larga para bajar el grado vale
pero bueno ahorita no hay que hacer eso
podemos pasar al siguiente paso y ese
consiste en factorizar el denominador en
encontrar sus factores vale entonces
cómo le podemos hacer para factorizar
este polinomio cúbico bueno usualmente
eso es mucho más difícil que factorizar
un polinomio cuadrática pero a lo mejor
aquí tenemos un poco de suerte por
ejemplo podemos utilizar esta idea si
encontramos un número
en el cual se anula esta expresión
entonces x es el número va a ser un
factor por ejemplo si ponemos x
igualados nos queda 2 al cubo que es 8
menos 8 entonces nos queda 0 eso lo que
nos dice es que x 2 es un factor vale o
sea si tenemos un 0 x ese 0 es un factor
así que déjame reescribir esto como 10 x
al cuadrado x al cuadrado más 12 x más
20 más 20 y eso dividido entre x2 x
menos 2 x una expresión que ahorita
vamos a determinar nada más antes de
determinar la déjame contarte un poco la
intuición de ese truco que hice
básicamente si tenemos un número que
anula a esta expresión también tiene que
anular a su factorización o se hace aquí
se hace 0 acá también se tiene que hacer
cero pero para que aquí al lado derecho
se haga cero algunos de los factores
debe de ser cero por eso ponemos un x
menos 2 para que cuando le pongamos x
igualados éste quede 0 y de adeveras el
denominador se haga 0 aquí también
pero vale bueno entonces ahora sí vamos
a determinar quién es esta expresión y
para eso vamos a utilizar división
polinómica larga déjame agarrar otro
color para hacerla de este lado entonces
voy a agarrar color naranja y voy a
poner afuera x2 x menos 2 muy bien y
adentro de la casita tiene que ir x al
cubo menos 8 entonces voy a poner aquí x
al cubo tengo que dejar una columna para
las expresiones cuadráticas una para las
expresiones lineales y finalmente va la
constante entonces aquí voy a poner el
menos 8 vale para que todo quede muy
bien ordenado no tienes por qué hacerlo
así pero si no lo haces así se pueden
amontonar las cosas bueno entonces
hagamos la división larga cuántas veces
cabe x en x al cubo pues x cuadrada va
en la columna de x cuadrada hacemos la
multiplicación de este x éste nos queda
x al cubo menos 2x cuadrado muy bien
ahora tenemos que restar tenemos que
restar eso es lo mismo que sumar el
negativo aquí nos quedan menos acá nos
queda más estos se van aquí nos queda 2x
cuadrado
ahora cuántas veces cabe x en 2x
cuadrada pues 2x entonces le ponemos más
2x muy bien entonces aquí está más 2x
multiplicamos 2x por x2 entonces nos
queda 2x cuadrada menos 4x menos 4x aquí
hay 10 x sale restamos aquí es menos
aquí es más estos se cancelan aquí nos
queda 4 x baje al menos 8 y ahora
cuántas veces cabe x en 4x pues 4 le
sumamos 4 y multiplicamos 4 por x 24 x
menos 8 y cuando hacemos la resta se
cancela todo sale éste se va con este
queda 0 y eso está padre porque justo
nos dice que x 2 si es un factor así que
esta expresión nos queda de la siguiente
forma la voy a poner aquí abajo como 10
x al cuadrado más 12 x más 20 más 20
dividido entre x menos 2 x menos 2 x x
al cuadrado
+ 2 x + 4 + 4 muy bien es justo lo que
encontramos por acá vale bueno ahora sí
vamos a hacer la descomposición en
fracciones parciales y aquí es donde se
complica un poco más de lo que hicimos
en el vídeo anterior de hecho aquí es
donde vamos a aprender más cosas
entonces deja de ponerle que esto es
igual a y bueno la idea es que vamos a
poner una constante entre x menos 2 a
entre x menos 2 hasta ahorita todo va
igual
pero de este lado en vez de poner arriba
una constante voy a poner b x + c donde
veces son constantes y en el denominador
queda esta otra expresión de x al
cuadrado más 12 x más 4 y me vas a decir
oye pero porque se te ocurrió poner
arriba un b x + y bueno la intuición
detrás es que si en el denominador
tenemos un término de cierto grado
arriba tiene que ir uno de un grado
exactamente menor o sea de sí sí aquí
tenemos una expresión lineal que es de
grado 1 arriba tiene que ir una
expresión de grado 0 o sea una constante
que acá escuadra tica arribaban de
expresión lineal por eso él ve x más
vale bueno esa es la idea detrás ahora
también te puedes preguntar por qué no
factor izamos esto todavía más y el
chiste es que ya no lo vamos a poder
factorizar más porque ya no va a tener
raíces reales o sea si intentas
aplicarle la fórmula general para
encontrar otras raíces vas a ver que no
funciona o bueno te va a sacar números
complejos eso lo que nos dice es que
aquí en los reales ya no lo podemos
factorizar más ok entonces vamos súper
bien
tenemos que hacer ahora es realizar esta
suma aquí al lado derecho dejan cambiar
de color entonces de este lado tenemos
que desarrollar la suma hay que poner el
factor común de los denominadores que va
a ser x 2 x x al cuadrado más 2 x + 4
vale y ahora está
hay que multiplicarla por x al cuadrado
más 2 x 4 2 x 4 y esteve x c hay que
multiplicarlo por x2 entonces sería más
bx + c por x 2 uf apenitas cupo déjame
poner este acá entonces esta esta parte
vale esto está para allá bueno entonces
ya tenemos que la primera expresión es
igual a esta última aquí está en rojo y
aquí está como medio en rosa vuelta paso
a un rosa más fuerte pero ya que tenemos
esto expresado así podemos igualar los
numeradores vale entonces eso es lo que
voy a hacer aquí abajo
necesito igualar 10 x al cuadrado más 12
x más 20 y es x al cuadrado más 12 x más
20 sin más 20 vale con a x x al cuadrado
más 2 x 4
a por no sé qué dije pero es x al
cuadrado más 2 x 4 ya eso tenemos que
sumarle b x c b x ac y multiplicarlo por
x 2 por x menos 2 muy bien ahora
necesitamos encontrar a b y c para que
se cumpla esta igualdad si lo hacemos de
la forma lenta que no te he acabado de
contar muy bien va a ser muy latosos o
nos va a quedar un sistema de ecuaciones
en tres variables y eso no está tan
fácil de resolver mejor vamos a usar el
mismo truco que en el primer vídeo y
vamos a encontrar algunos valores de x
que nos permitan ir cancelando las
constantes de cierto lado para obtener
así una ecuación muy sencilla en la otra
constante vamos a ver a qué me refiero
vale entonces déjame tomar este color
azul y lo primero que vamos a hacer es
evaluar en x igual a 2
esto lo hacemos para que esto se haga un
0 y ya no nos importa en la vela sé por
qué aquí estaríamos multiplicando por 0
entonces déjame ponerle en x igualados y
voy a poner una flechita para ver qué
nos pasa si x es igual a 2
aquí nos queda 10 x
2 al cuadrado 2 al cuadrado es 4
entonces nos queda 40 más 12 por 224 más
20 es igual a
por 2 al cuadrado que es cuatro más dos
por 244
muy bien mira de este lado ya no queda
nada esto se hace 0 entonces ya nos
queda una ecuación lineal en a vamos a
resolverla de este lado nos queda 84 84
es igual a 12 y dividiendo entre 12 a
ambos lados nos queda que a es igual a 7
muy bien ya hicimos un poquito de
progreso ya tenemos que a es igual a 7
vamos a seguirle entonces ahora vamos a
intentar eliminar otra de las variables
por ejemplo b para eliminar b podemos
poner x igual a 0 y eso suena muy buena
idea porque muchas cosas se van a hacer
0 entonces eso suena padre vamos a
hacerlo para ver qué nos queda vamos a
poner ahora en esta misma de acá arriba
x igual a 0 y ahora podemos aprovechar
que ya sabemos que a es igual a 7
entonces aquí nos queda 0 0 y 20
entonces nos queda que 20 es igual a que
es 7 x 0 0 4
por 4 más estévez no nos importa porque
se multiplica por 0 más se hace por 0 -
2 o sea por menos 2 por menos 2 muy bien
entonces que nos queda nos queda que 20
es igual a 28 menos 2 c pasamos el 28 a
la izquierda o restamos 28 de ambos
lados como quieras pensarlo nos queda
que menos 8 y es igual a menos 2 c y
dividiendo entre menos 2 ambos lados de
la igualdad nos queda que se es igual a
esto está fantástico ya tenemos dos de
las variables muy bien ahora ya nada más
nos falta determinar el valor de b y la
idea para determinar el valor de b es
que ya conocemos a hicimos así que vamos
a poner una equis que nos simplifica las
cuentas pero que no cancele a b por
ejemplo x igual a 1 entonces déjame
poner x igual a 1 entonces vamos a poner
por acá x igual a 1 para ver qué nos
queda nos quedaría 10 más 12 más 20
10 12 20 es igual a a ya sabemos que
vale 7 7 por 12 4 y 7 más
ve se vale 4 entonces es b más 4 x 1 -
21 menos 2 es igual a menos 1 x menos 1
vamos a realizar las operaciones
intentaré no equivocarme esto de aquí
nos queda 42
es igual a 49 más bueno en realidad
vamos a distribuir este menos 1 entonces
este va para allá éste va para acá me ve
menos 4 vamos bien entonces ahora vamos
a restar este 4 nos queda 42 es igual a
45 b y ahora este 45 lo restamos de
ambos lados nos queda menos 3 voy a
poner por acá menos 3 es igual a menos
ve a menos b y por lo tanto b es igual a
3 muy bien muy muy bien está fantástico
ya tenemos a b y c y por lo tanto ya
podemos reescribir nuestra nuestra
expresión racional con en su desarrollo
en fracciones parciales entonces déjame
pasar me digamos para acá si aquí
tenemos la expresión entonces ahora ésta
está ya no está sino que es 7 esta vez
ya no es b sino que es 3 según recuerdo
esta vez 3 tal vez tres y éstas no s
sino que es un 4 y de esta forma la
expansión o desarrollo en fracciones
parciales nos queda como 7 dividido
déjame ponerlo en un color un poco más
notorio de que ella es la respuesta en
color blanco
entonces nos quedan siete dividido entre
x
2 - 2 + 3 x + 4 / / / x al cuadrado más
2 x más 4 excelente y esto que estoy
poniendo en el rectángulo es la
respuesta al problema sale entonces como
puedes ver este ejemplo estuvo mucho más
complicado estuvo más largo de hacer
pero espero que te haya sido de ayuda
para ver otro tipo de problemas que te
puedes encontrar cuando hagas ejercicios
de descomposición en fracciones
parciales